shut down in deutschland stillstand der
staat greift tief in die grundrechte ein
leben retten auf der einen seite schaden
anrichten auf der anderen stimmte die
verhältnismäßigkeit bald kommt wieder
ein herbst
2022 und wieder die frage welche
maßnahme ist geeignet welche angemessen
schon bei der ersten prüfungsstufe der
geeignetheit muss nämlich der
gesetzgeber belegen dass die von ihm
getroffene maßnahmen auch wirklich
wirksam ist und das muss mit
naturwissenschaftlichen daten belegen
doch eben diese daten gibt es in
deutschland kaum meisten aus dem ausland
das weiß der expertinnen expertenrat der
bundesregierung und kritisiert es auch
trotzdem gibt der rat am vergangenen
mittwoch empfehlungen für den herbst
schließt auch einen shutdown nicht aus
in der günstigsten variante die da
beschrieben war wäre bei einem
ungünstigsten verlauf wahrscheinlich
ohne kontakt beschränkung in diesem
sinne denkbar wir halten sie im moment
nicht für besonders wahrscheinlich gab
es fehler in der vergangenheit das
urteil so milde wie es nur sein kann
auch ersparen und die
vorgänger-regierung haben wirklich gute
sagten gemachte lauter war für viele
sachen jetzt auch gut fort es ist nicht
gut nach hinten zu schauen blickt man
trotzdem zurück vielen studien
dokumentationen bislang wurde das auch
nicht aufgeholt der
bundesgesundheitsminister der
wissenschaftsbasierte politik beim
amtsantritt versprach verspricht jetzt
daten technisch nachzurüsten
wir bereiten derzeit die erfassung der
daten in den krankenhäusern vor der
vorschlag dem der expertenrat hier macht
dieses instrument dem ist zu nutzen
genau dieser vorschlag wird seit einigen
monaten auch bei mir im haus vorbereitet
und die technischen vorbereitungen
laufen auf hochtouren auf hochtouren im
dritten jahr der pandemie
also erst einmal gar und satiren dass er
schon skandalös dass man nach drei
jahren überhaupt gar keine belastbaren
zahlen hat denn sie brauchen doch zahlen
daten fakten um solche maßnahmen in
irgendeiner art und weise überhaupt zu
rechtfertigen wie das jetzt drei jahre
lang gelaufen ist ist einfach mit dem
mit dem holzhammer
maßnahmen verhängt worden sind alles zu
alles auf oder ich sag mal auch nach der
frage welche stärkste lobby sich der
politisch durchsetzen kann das muss
wirklich aufhören das kann man nicht
mehr den menschen vermitteln neben dem
expertenrat gibt es einen sogenannten
sachverständigenausschuss der bis zum 30
juni an gutachten vorlegen soll
sozusagen ein kult maßnahmen zeugnis die
mitglieder des ausschusses übrigens
einen drittel juristen bis vor zehn
tagen kein einziger epidemiologe dieser
ausschuss soll die auswirkungen der
regelung und die wirksamkeit der
getroffenen massnahmen untersuchen doch
auch im ausschuss mangelnde daten aus
deutschland kaum personal kein geld da
fragt sich selbst der vorsitzende ist
der ausschuss auf dem falschen gleis
schon vor veröffentlichung des
gutachtens politischer streit die fdp
will die ergebnisse abwarten die grünen
wollen jetzt maßnahmen für den herbst
festlegen die feuerwehr fängt auch nicht
an erst die schläuche auszurollen und
die feuerwache zu bauen wenn dann der
brand im gange ist sondern sorgt vor das
muss politik auch im pandemie management
tun wir bremsen überhaupt nicht wir
haben ja einen fahrplan für das gesamte
jahr im frühjahr festgelegt am 30 juni
kommt die evaluierung von gesetzlich
eingesetzten gremium und dann werden wir
über dem sommer das auswerten und können
nach der sommerpause in einem ganz
geordneten gesetzgebungsverfahren
dann die konsequenzen beschließen das
aktuelle infektionsschutzgesetz gilt bis
zum 23 september es sollte reformiert
werden auch auf grundlage ausgewertete
daten doch es gibt keine systematik und
irgendwie auch keine verantwortung
es ist die politische geschichte von
daten löchern und unsicheren aussichten
wie schützt man die bevölkerung
wasserbar schadet ihr es gibt mehr
fragen als antworten